I take it you've heard the name Abraham
brand they call him the preacher I
believe he resides in our own bodies
turning up there the river find out the
root of these killings time is of the
essence what brings y'all their swag saw
smoke thought we'd see some lodgings
rest our horses you need to see the
preacher
we have new yes welcome to Mount Hermon
how long will you be staying long enough
to rest a few days Abraham frightens me
David you are in search of something
but some strange twist of fate Abraham
saying that killed my father took me
years ago David you will kill this man
you're not safe I've tried to leave this
place I say he's been touched by God in
His free
you're not feeling well no if you're
fine no now you have the fever it's not
right Dre yeah you have no idea what's
going on here I'm a Texas Ranger I'll be
sent by the governor himself bother
chasing this man my kind of live
how are you through my wife
even's be damned who say one word and
I'll blow my head off he's put you in
the river thank you dear father
take him
for me David
I'm guessing you didn't foresee this